german foreign minister analina babak is
in vilnius as she wraps up a three-day
trip to the three baltic states russia's
invasion of ukraine has dominated the
agenda during her trip speaking
alongside her lithuanian counterpart
bearbox stressed germany's support for
the nato alliance and for strengthening
regional security in the face of the
growing threat from russia she also
played down the prospect of a quick
ceasefire much less an end to the war in
ukraine
and the ukrainians alone get to decide
their future
we should not be under any illusions
about that
as bitter and as difficult as it may be
to accept
having tried time and again to reach a
common security policy in europe with
russia as our partner
putin's russia has forced us to take a
new path
spring in our political correspondent
hans blonde here hans the german foreign
minister there saying europe needs to
protect itself from russia did she offer
any details on how europe should do that
well she's been saying in these baltic
states that she's visited for the last
three days that every inch every last
corner of the nato territory would be
defended against russia in the case of
an attack from russia and the last
corner she was talking about was the
baltic states in those states there has
been for the last five years or so
the so-called tripwire
policy they have stationed smaller units
of nato troops there and if russia
should attack those units and that would
trip the response from the nato
countries
against russia and the baltic states
have said that is not enough that this
is not enough protection for them in the
light of how russia has operated in
ukraine and the german foreign minister
has now said that she supports the
calls by the baltic states to increase
the military pressure the presence of
nato countries nato
troops in their states germany itself
has stationed quite a large number of
troops in lithuania and is prepared to
increase those
now berbach has been touring those three
baltic states over the past few days
all those states have called on germany
to do more for ukraine including
delivering weapons has there been any
movement by the german government on
that front hunts
yes there's been some confusion
especially in terms of communication
from various members of the german
government about this in the last few
days and now i think some clarity has
emerged germany is not going to deliver
heavy weapons out of its own arsenals
because it says it just simply does not
have them available what's going to
happen is that slovenia as the first
country will deliver heavy weapons will
deliver tanks to ukraine and those gaps
that are now that then exist in slovenia
will be filled by supplies from germany
within a few weeks or months so this
kind of chain reaction as it were
has been agreed on in addition germany
is offering to give not only money but
also
maintenance and training for some of the
systems that are going to be supplied
and some of that training is likely to
happen in lithuania and other baltic
states
hans thank you very much our political
correspondent huntsman